on a demandé aux personnes nous poser
des questions sur les réseaux alors il
ya cinq questions qui ressortent
vraiment la première ses bâtons devoir
se faire vacciner tous les six mois bon
on a vu et on en a parlé comment est-ce
que ce que certains croient voilà on
venait pas vraiment un farouche opposant
la vaccination c'est ce que vous m'aviez
dit déjà le premier jour de l'émission
mais ces derniers temps on parle
beaucoup de troisième dose de même de
quatrième dose c'est ce qui explique et
gabriela talent le porte parole du
gouvernement encore ce matin est ce
qu'on va devoir se faire vacciner tous
les six mois comme ça à l'air de se
profiler gens ça ya d'abord pour vous
rassurer effectivement si vous étiez
inquiet je suis pas du tout j'ai fait
moi dans ce pays rembourser de vaccins
qui était pas rembourser avant que
j'arrive d'accord d'accord donc c'est
une chose et deuxièmement je trouve au
contraire dans ce pays on a un retard
sur la vaccination
pour la grippe chez les enfants qui est
une maladie qui peut être mortelle chez
laurent ruquier 38 par les enfants sur
le vary ciel qui étaient remboursés
depuis 20 ans aux états unis tepa votée
rembourser chez nous et puis sur
rotavirus qui est l'agent des gastro
entérite qui quand ils effet fait
diminué de 30 % des hospitalisations
d'enfants donc tout ça je les écris
fallait que je les écris donc c'était
simplement pour les vaccins comme pour
le reste c'est la curiosité de le lire
sur je ne vais pas l'acheter je
l'enverrai je dis la même chose on peut
pas leur dire vous êtes pour ou contre
les vaccins être une question idiote il
ya des vaccins c'est savoir
pour qui voilà c'est ça à quel moment
vous n'êtes pas quel âge voilà c'est ça
veut dire que c'est une question qui est
une question médicale est d'ailleurs
vous à la fois vous m'aviez mais pris
par surprise et donc je vous ai pas
répondu
je vais y répondre maintenant brigands
baisse que vous diriez 6
john pham venez vous demander
si vous voulez vous accédez voilà après
les cours elle déjà ce que je dirais
pour pour la même jeune femme est encore
une fois parce que je crois qu'il reste
un rôle pour médecin alors que j'avais
juste quelqu'un en bonne santé qui à mon
sens un compte en voilà pour qui tout va
très bien ça dépend de la personne qui
est en face de moi si c'est une personne
qui est pas en surpoids ou obèses
vraiment vraiment obama m'a dit je suis
dirait vaccinez vous parce que les gens
comme vous qui attrapent la maladie en
meurent d'accord d'accord c'est un
premier point deuxièmement s'il ya
quelqu'un qui dit écoutez j'ai tellement
peur d'être mal du tout même vacciné je
lui dirai écouter vaccinez vous c'est
quelqu'un qui me dit écoutez je suis
terrifiée par ce vaccin et j'ai peur
d'avoir des effets secondaires de
médecin je dirais que de 2,2 du vaccin
je veux y aurait coûté pour l'instant et
tant que vous n'êtes pas dans une
situation épidémique c'est pas
nécessaire voyez donc tu vois j'ai
chaque personne on dit en fonction moi
je crois au conseil médical et je pense
qu'un des problèmes qu'on a avec le
vaccin c'est que on pense que l'état
peut décider à la place des médecins qui
est la situation de chacun moi je crois
que la situation dépend des uns et les
autres si quelqu'un j'ai dit les gens
qui sont les soignants qui sont au
contact avec des gens qui ont un risque
d'avoir la peau vide ils ont beaucoup
plus de raison d'être vaccinées que les
autres parce que ils vont la trappe et
donc en particulier ceux qui sont très
au contact bien sûr donc si vous avez
une surexposition aux risques ou si vous
faites partie de la population qui
risque de faire une forme grave ou d'en
mourir vous avez un bénéfice à vous
faites maintenant pour vous répondre sur
sur le les booster pour l'instant c'est
clair pour personne ça y est il vient de
sortir un papier de trois pages dans
l'antre 16 qui discutent là dessus en
ayant finalement il faut pas le faire il
ya des gens qui disent non mais
finalement il faut le faire à part
pareil pour la population à risque qui
est la population des gens qui risquent
de faire une forme grave d'accord mais
c'est vrai que ce que ça veut dire c'est
que l'efficacité du vaccin petit à petit
avec le temps a diminué mais le plus
courte que ce qu'on imaginait d'accord
la ccsa problème aussi alors moi de ce
que je décrive de ce que vous dites
c'est que une personne qui en
excellente santé qui a peur du vaccin ou
lui dit pour l'instant attendre un petit
peu oui pour pour une raison c'est que
pour une raison c'est que il ya il ya
beaucoup d'effets secondaires qui sont
des frais induits si vous voulez par par
la peur c'est ça je serai donc c'est à
dire ça la peur une fois qu'on s'est
fait injecter loyer c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet nocebo si vous voulez
aussi mais ça fait des années j'ai des
crises a aussi et bien longtemps si si
quand on commence à faire un vaccin ou
on compare toujours à fond boxe à
ajaccio dos avec du sel dedans et donc
vous mesurer les effets immédiats dans
la plupart des cas les effets immédiats
si vous faites ça sur 1000 personnes les
effets immédiats ne sont pas différents
donc le problème de l'accès à ses
exploits il faut en avoir fait cent
mille deux cent mille trois cent mille
pour voir s'il ya des effets souvent des
alors quand vous en faites 1000 ou 2000
ou 5000 vous le voyez pas mais si vous
regardez à côté de ça avec non pas un
placebo là c'est un aussi bon de 50 ans
oui c'est le contraire c'est le
contraire si regardez ce que ça fait
bien vous verrez il ya des gens qui ont
de la fièvre ya des gens qui ont des
boutons il ya des gens c'est
psychologique oui oui c'est fait pas ça
on s'est très très bien analysé
maintenant les gens qui savent pas ça
c'est parce qu'ils sont ignorants
si c'est bon les chercher chez rsa ou
les jo qui quitte à l'arbre si vous
voulez de ses surnoms b ccc décrit un
très très beau papier la turquie montre
exactement par ces on connaît le
médiateur chimiques de ça qu'elle a
collé aux pertes donc un médecin doit le
savoir ça il doit dire vous avez faut
mieux il vaut mieux éviter en tout cas
s'il le fait il doit expliquer à son
patient le rassurer suffisamment pour
qu'il n'est pas l'effet nocebo la corse
assassin d'hui aussi vous savez les gens
poussent à la sophrologie à toutes
sortes de techniques de relaxation qui
amène que c'est effet nocebo
disparaissent si on les fait s'évaluer
temps qu'il voyait donc c'est tout un
protocole quoi faut pas le faire
n'importe comment alors on va parler de
moi moi sur ce qui m'arrive à moi j'ai
déjà on veut des comptes touche
m'évanouis
la vaccination des enfants de moins de
12 ans n'est pas encore à l'ordre du
jour en france on en parle de plus en
plus un sujet qui divise énormément vous
en pensez quoi vous professeurs pour
l'instant en pot pour le moins de 12 ans
je crois pas du tout qui est de
consensus sérieuse sur le fait qu'il
faille direction est donc d'accord je
suis pas du tout convaincu parce que
l'une des choses qui est très étonnante
dans cette épidémie qui n'est pas
vraiment étonnante si on creuse c'est
que en 2020 comme en 2021 la mortalité
chez les gens de moins de 45 ans et plus
basse que dans toutes les années
précédentes d'accord il est difficile de
dire quand même c'est une population
risque au contraire le le ca si j'ai un
message de santé publique et la trad à
haroun répéter répéter répéter que je
passais ma vie et répété c'est la
décontamination des ans démarre on a eu
les d'aller à une chance incroyable on
n'a pas eu une infection respiratoire
grippale ni de virus respiratoire
syncytial ni de diarrhée et ça c'est
l'alcool sur les mains cette année c'est
reparti parce que je pense qu'on
n'oublie l'alcool sur les mains parce
que l'un dernière il y avait que
l'alcool sur les marques et que donc on
a déjà donné la vie quotidienne qui
viennent qui est de se nettoyer les
mains c'est qui a fait disparu fait
nettoyer les bonnes touches à 0 chez
nous et partout dans le monde nous on
s'est fait ce coupé parce qu'on voulait
prêter le plus vite mais il ya eu 2
publie papier publié avant le nôtre sur
la disparition des maladies
transmissibles banal simplement dans le
cadre de du coville ou de lakovic vous
parler du sexe des anges c'est samedi 10
exactement on va dire la comité